goes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to dumb people town a place
that we all feel like we live glad to
have time here man I'm happy to be back
that was just the one time I did it
before no fun so fun man you're great
dude so the best is I recently saw Brian
in the airport uh you were on your way
to a gig to run away and it was like
five in the morning and we had just
found out that our feature comic had to
drop out for that night all I wanted to
do was just catch up with you and hang
out and talk but I was like in crisis
mode so we're here sorry now we can
enjoy ourselves here I see everybody at
the airport right yeah so my favorite
thing is at the airport there is in and
we've maybe talked about this in the
American Airlines terminal there's a
sports bar there called home turf I'm
like who's home first of all the airport
is no one's home term this is where
you're never like hey honey my flight
got in but I'm gonna stick around and
watch the Patriots game is that weird
that I want to just get the guys
together and spend 100 on parking I
think when we run through there right
running to my flight it would be pretty
great if they named it the visitors
section the visitors section that's what
it should have been but it works on
every level nobody's home turf that's no
one's home bar yeah it's cooler than
Rock and Brews Rock and Brews is always
I'm a kiss fan but yeah I'm not going in
Rock and Brews ever you won't even sit
outside of it and like right here just
shaking my head Rock and bruises feels
sad in terminal one there's a sadness to
it rocking bruises I want to rock and
roll all night and party every other day
yeah yeah that's it you got it what you
want is like you know a Chili's two will
never let you down that feels airport
worthy I like that there's a lemonade
across I agree that's agreed we'll go in
there's no person that goes to the
lemonade and then also goes to rock yes
my dream is that someday The Cheesecake
Factory gets into this airport game and
they have the Cheesecake Factory Outlet
and that is just a little Cheesecake
Factory so the menu is only what would
you use a thousand Pages yeah so half
it's half of what a regular cheesecake
menu is like an encyclopedia way too
much so the last Harry Potter book
is shorter than the cheesecake don't you
you know what I'm taking these as
positives not negatives all right so
here's the I'm first so here's the deal
Brian the last time you did it Danny had
all three stories we've changed it up
Dan has a story Randy has a story I have
a story all you have to do we're moving
on from LAX
but I bet we come back but I bet we can
we could do a whole podcast
you want an 11 peanut butter and jelly
sandwich I've seen some dumb people oh
my god I've spent 20 on a sandwich
before for no reason okay all right so
this is so now we actually have a
somewhat of a food related story right
perfect I'm very excited so here we go
this is sent in by eggnog pounder okay
and I just drank a small glass of eggnog
today
and I felt hang on woozy sick passed out
what are you doing where are you going
I'm gonna get because it when it printed
out it didn't uh have the I want to get
the correct
um eggnog pounder is the name okay and
it's no
I mean a lot of our Foods were probably
created as a mistake right so David
tells joke was I want to get drunk but I
also want pancakes
so but I I just it was in our fridge but
I also want pancakes
pancakes yeah that's it all right so
here we go so this is sent in here is
the headline and this is just CR
everything about this is is crazy and
how it went down but it's almost the
universe actually doing something right
so here we go emu and Chef
is this the those Liberty Mutual
commercials
help stop driver fleeing crash site so
now they're fighting run it back for me
so there's an emu and then the chef see
somebody get into an accident it's just
like an old man Street joke that's what
this sounds like and even if you just
see a car accident let's move on so are
we are we pooped on the guy that's right
so again this is Limu emu and Doug
territory yeah old Chef an old chef and
a massive emu now my question is do they
know each other ahead of time yeah they
feel like a pair right and it or was he
about to serve emu and was like all
right old buddy let's do one last just
the best description you can get an old
Chef old chef and a massive emu who
inadvertently teamed up to catch a
driver who fled a crash scene after
narrowly missing pedestrians and causing
extensive damage season two of The Bear
there you go stop Dean Wade said he
heard a loud screeching noise do you
Wade Superman
right that's Dean came near his
workplace uh in Wilshire uh Southwest
England on Monday raced out to see a
Jeep careening before smashing into the
front of an empty shop so he sees
someone have you seen like a crazy car
accident like you've seen you have I've
seen him oh yeah I thought I was the son
of Satan because I saw too many
accidents
I thought [ __ ] was happening if I'm
looking at it it's gonna happen
dude we just had really terrible roads
and a lot of rain and a lot of rain yeah
and I was on my paper out all the time
yeah so I would just see stuff randomly
happen in front of me and I was like how
do you not think you're part of a Paul
Thomas Anderson you're the harbinger I'm
the thing that's connecting all these
things oh God that's crazy all right so
we've been an interview with the
Washington Post on Wednesday Wade who
had been working at the Old Bell Hotel
definitely haunted okay let me ask you
that's definitely hot first of all did
did you Yelp it no I did not I should
have yelled people don't you dare Jay
Yelp it okay Yelp at the old you can
find a toe okay right now I want us to
just our name alone this is one of my
favorite things nice hotel shitty hotel
yeah terrible terrible do you think but
would it blow you away if you found out
I was like no it's hourly rate
but it could be a 600 a night 15 minute
rate the old Bell hotel in England hey
uh can we see that oh in England that's
right we're in England yeah we're in
England can we see the old Bill no it's
broken and I think the old Bell hotels
gone internet yeah yeah it's Abby Rose
Abbey Road the old Bell Hotel so it's
probably like 400 years old let's do a
guess right now uh that's the old Bell
out of there's four reviews okay out of
five stars how many stars how many stars
you think the old Bell I love Jerry one
and a half I'd say 3.5 oh that's I'm
gonna go three
get your answers in and Shout out your
ham radio or your YouTube how many days
okay the old Bell has out of four
reviews
four or three and a half Stars okay
thank you very much
I'm guessing things right in my own
story all right he'd only been working
uh in the in the Old Bell hotel in in
malmesbury for only two weeks uh said he
could see the driver who appeared drunk
so you knew that that was happening was
getting ready to back away from the
scene of female passenger had left the
vehicle so this guy crashes into stuff a
woman hops out it's like I can't have
this anymore his date is over
I said take me home tonight no we can't
sing that there's there's no way you're
going anywhere way toward the man who
said he was swaying and staggering all
over the place he said the man was
determined to escape heading off on foot
so now leaves the car which I this I saw
this happen to me once you saw someone
cause an accident I was on Beverly just
east of Vine okay and I'm coming up and
I see a weird swear you know you can't
process like why are those headlights
going now yeah and they had they drove
into a like one of those like cement
protector not a fence it's like a wall
yeah especially if you're living along
Beverly right and uh it was a SUV a Jeep
oh my God and like this yeah and they
drove straight into the wall the tire
was like bent sideways like horizontal
away from the car and like kind of in
the wall and just try this two young
women and uh the woman in the thing she
is revving it trying to reverse out of
the wall they're both hammered drunk I
just reached in and grabbed the keys you
reached into their car and grabbed the
keys yeah cause I was like you're not go
hey are you okay and then I realized
they were stronger than they were like
we got them you are so too involved in
their life when you do that they were
even if they got out they were gonna
just drive into oncoming traffic police
officer would you Brian has something I
say I've done something similar yes
thank you Brian my first night in
Hollywood I was actually staying in one
of those terrible hotels on Sunset way
down there yeah where your Earwolf used
to be yeah yeah yeah it's sketchy area
but it was the 80s and I came down and I
fought with my buddy that we were
staying at a hotel together and I got in
a fight with him over something so I was
skateboarding down the middle of the
street and it's the 80s middle of the
night yeah and I see a guy get his arm
ripped off what on a motorcycle
oh my God loses his arm he's in shock
another guy grabs him and you grab the
arm no he got the arm and he's holding
his arm sitting on the curb the woman
who hit him jumped out of her car and
then books it down the street running
yeah and you know those like shitty bars
and there's like uh
um laundromats all night laundry yes
yeah I was on my skateboard so I just
followed up followed her oh my God and
the cops are coming and I helped the
cops find her I go you know right there
in the laundromat so you like
19.99 one night Welcome to Hollywood 85
1986. I love that you gave the cops a
hand
before that like in junior high in high
school but this is yeah yeah this is two
night one okay it's my first night in
the city and I was like this is only L.A
always like this and then you went back
to your friend you're like you're gonna
argue with a guy who just helped the
cops find him yeah I went back and when
you dude you'll never believe he's still
mad but you're like no we're past that I
just saw a dude
oh god dude
by the way that may be one of the most
insane stories
all right so stagging all over the place
said the man was determined to escape
heading off on foot though unable to run
fast due to his physical state of course
he's probably like this woman
he was probably in shock a little bit
too oh for sure so wearing his slip
resistant rubber kitchen cloth yeah
because he works Chef just call him and
Chef's overalls Wade chased the driver
for how long how give me a range of
minutes he chased this guy on foot in
his in his
I think he ran for like 30 minutes in
these goddamn you'd be so tired
yeah you'd be dead I know you're trying
to just call him Crocs but still you can
run in trucks I can't I I you can't run
for a sustained period I'll go ten but
if it's 15. one of you is one minute off
oh do you want to now go up or do you go
up or down as a you say 11. another I
would tell Brian go up a minute because
I bet they rounded 15. all right Jay
29. My Hope Is that it's 11. Wade chased
the driver for 15 to 20 minutes yeah
there you go through bushes allotments
and Gardens before the pair ended up in
an animal sanctuary oh my God this is
where the Emu comes I thought the Emu
was just cruising around I did too
he was just hanging out checking out the
bars fighting crime so he's on the he
moves chasing the woman right I could
see this massive emu Wade said I'm six
foot tall and it was bigger than me so
thank you
Brians are frightening yeah have you
guys been to the park by Solvang that
like you move no no I think you can feed
that they are stop are they wild wild
right here my mom was a flag
my mom's as frightening
lady oh God oh my God so this Wade said
he could tell the bird which was
surrounded by its Offspring was likely
to spring into defense if anyone came
into the enclosure
with its Birds
and he said may he said mate don't go in
there Ward warned the man who had
ignored his advice because let's face it
he just crashed into a storefront his
date left and his girlfriend has been
chasing him for 15 minutes yeah who
ignored his advice replying and this is
why this is a dumb people Town story all
of it's a dumb people sound but this
guy's quote is maybe quote of the year
I can fight emus that's what he said
damn it I can fight Hubris in that like
someone thinking they have that well
here's a real before fight anything
you'll just move before heading into the
animals pen where he was I feel like
he's he's been around in emu before to
decide that he can fight one no but I
think that's just something like no bro
just what I've read I'm pretty sure
you want to go for the neck I could
fight emus is what he said and I can
fight it before heading into the animals
pen where he was repeatedly packed yeah
really that's in there oh yeah it was
stabbing his body all over causing the
man to curse and unsuccessful that would
hurt unsuccessfully attempt to Kung Fu
kick the animal
[ __ ] you dude
that's right in front of it's babies
like the bird kept stabbing at the
driver who evidently who eventually get
up gave up fled the band and headed
toward the river her he's now taken this
to the river while Wade took the
opportunity to flag down a nearby police
car back so again there is someone
sitting at his restaurant being like
where where's our appetizer yeah you
know if you guys aren't going to even
bring our food we'll just go we'll just
get there what's this guy doing like
chasing a guy down the street and then
doing emo Farms pulling out like police
they're out of bread
all right so the police said they uh
said they were dealing with a minor
injury and extensive damage following
the Collision that forced the road to
close his Emergency Services
search of the area officials said one
person had been arrested for driving
drunk they didn't name the suspect we
know who it is Mr Emu so this is an
England story Wade just told the post
you just relocated from a very sprawling
city of Leeds to the picturesque Village
of malmsbury for his new job at the Old
Bell Hotel uh which claims to be
England's oldest hotel that's what they
claim to be according to the website
according to the website this is we can
I mean there's really not that much else
here but according to the website oh
we'll get there there's a couple more
when was this hotel the old Bell Hotel
Don't Do You Remember Jay or no
[Music]
before I even did the math that's what I
was thinking I'm gonna go I mean it's
England's oldest hotel right or what
they're claiming to be yeah this is
their claim but still we it's a number
so we can [ __ ] I'm gonna go 1550s get
your answers in town you're not even
gonna let you do it because I think you
probably saw it uh it said the venue has
served Travelers since
at a certain point no one can verify if
you're lying so this is what you got to
go so far back that I love this Wade
said in leads we don't stand by and do
nothing uh he credited yeah this guy
want to be a hero his home city of West
Yorkshire uh and his passion for justice
for Provo bringing with the instinct to
chase the drivers emus are classified as
one of the world's biggest birds
according to National Geographic the
animal can weigh up to how many pounds
and grow how tall
so that's hard to guess the weight
either it's all neck and length right
and they're kind of and they yeah 350
350 and how tall and how tall are you
saying my height six six six six six
okay what do you say I think seven feet
tall and I think they can get up to 200
pounds okay Dan I like that I'm gonna go
eight feet oh God
and because I remember like looking up
but maybe yeah they can get up there but
maybe not that I'll still stick with it
eight feet and I'm gonna stick with the
number I said even though when you said
350 I think it could be I'm gonna go 150
pounds what did you say I said 200 all
right so this is what National
Geographic said so yeah maybe different
animals can weigh up to 97 pounds okay
and grow over six feet tall so over six
feet tall you guys both might be right
while they cannot burn these Mountain
Dog about that big yeah exactly
they have long powerful legs that they
often use to kick Predators if they come
too close it's gonna stomp your ass and
that is Story one down
Brandon all right let's talk about
Brian's got new Comics that he's done
which we'll talk about that on the other
side of the break wait he's got some
dates on the road maybe a little bit
yeah
all right on the other side of the break
it's dumb people town with Brian post
saying all things comedy hope you're
watching this on YouTube subscribe smash
yeah
stick around
show before we get into all the awesome
stuff Ryan is doing uh we want to remind
people that uh La first weekend in
February we'll be at the American Comedy
Company down in San Diego second through
the fourth I love that venue and I
believe Jeff Tice is going to be with us
yeah
fantastic and then on that Sunday night
we're going to go up to sketchfest I
know Brian pose and has performed at
sketchfest we love it up there
so guys come on out we want to fill that
up I know that's a big room it's 400
seats but I think we can I think we can
at the very least fill the bottom but I
love doing it it's going to be so much
fun waiting for you guys to get up there
because on uh the fourth on Saturday I
will be doing stand-up at sketchfest and
then you can see me every Wednesday at
the lyric Hyperion theater doing the
lyric Comedy Hour uh that's a show from
Myself and Irene two everything else is
it Daniel Van Kirk and supersclash.com
for us all right you brought these guys
Bry what what talk to us about these uh
so this is the thing I did with uh Jerry
Duggan who
we were Partners on Deadpool together
and then we got our same artist uh Scott
koblish was well we had several artists
on Deadpool but he was one of our
favorite guys that got comedy yeah and
so we did this first one it was called
the secret history of the war on weed
which is
self-explanatory Brian I know that you
came out on 420 and then the second one
is Halloween party this character we
made Scotch Tiernan uh he's kind of um
we have him working for Nancy Reagan in
the beginning to go up and fight the war
on Wii like with his actual fists yeah
but uh then it's good it goes from there
now he's fighting monsters and okay and
the artwork was so insanely good here
it's just it's it's beautiful Scott's
one of the most talented dudes I've ever
worked like I've gotten into uh writing
comics on the side became a you know a
fun thing but now I'm because of covid I
have like four books coming out next
year are you serious I got really busy
like with all these ideas and then
hooked up with all these different
artists and I have different writers I'm
working with so my God I love that this
is like this is a first of all people I
love Comics people love original ideas
because they're there's a lot of comics
are like born out of things that they've
seen over over time so when a new comic
hits the market people love it I'm sure
it's like a big deal this is like yeah
it's got a bunch of it's we threw like
every 80s action movie cliche in a
blender like he's like Commando and
Cobra and all those kind of movies
really over the top and then he has like
catchphrases that he you know like stick
around that kind of thing from
Schwarzenegger and yeah uh and then holy
[ __ ] comedy like yes yeah yeah and so
because I feel like a lot of comic books
aren't funny anymore everything got
super serious and the ones the reason I
loved writing Deadpool for four years
was that we got to do anything dumb that
we thought of and and people like you
associate comedy with that brand 100 so
it's I just love it okay so where can
people get these every comic shop and
then they'll be uh collected in a trade
in the spring so I love it so do you go
to Comic-Con and have these out yeah I
signed the first book the uh secret war
was out during this last summer and then
I'll be there this summer I'm gonna be
at American Comedy Company myself during
Comic-Con great I've already booked it
like oh I did that last year too so
right I'm gonna ask you to sign a couple
I will yeah yeah these are really cool
so I brought these for you guys
Halloween party and the secret War on
Drugs
I love it you get it get on and people
can find all your dates you got any
specials coming up brianjustine.com and
then posting and I'm grata
dude the best titles the farthest is my
favorite title of any special I am
you know like I didn't even see the
artist I did not see the artist you
didn't need to that movie
I don't put up a graphic of I copied the
poster of the artist so funny I had to
actually shave my beard I know part of
it like it was like shadowed and like
yeah so it was a masculine part of me
had a beard and then the feminine part
of me was Fearless that sounds right
sure yeah it was we're hugging each
other like the artist it's so weird so
funny it is maybe like it's one of those
things like the title of something that
you see and you laugh and then you come
back to it later and you laugh and it
just I was like this is Never Gonna not
get me everything you guys know my
manager Dave rat yeah it just comes from
him like he's the we think of the
dumbest [ __ ] together and all like or or
I'll think of it on my own and go this
is so dumb and he'll go haha yeah you
should do it
uh it's gonna be everywhere next week
okay great but right now it's just on
moment.com
or whatever all right but it'll be when
this drops in January it'll be out over
here so it's everywhere everywhere so
you can get it Amazon you can get it uh
on you will it be on YouTube or yeah
okay where recorded where'd you record
it uh the Beat Kitchen in Chicago I love
the Beat Kitchen that's so cool where is
that Dan where is that uh it's in the
north part of the city just a little bit
West Roscoe Village area it's wonderful
it's right off the damn right off it's a
little metal bar yeah it's really cool
and and uh they're just they've always
been great to me and it just made sense
to to do it there and then they were
super happy to have me back like
especially after covet and like you know
like places like that went away and that
place was uh able to stick it out and
stay through it's great so it's a
celebration of that place as well so
everybody check it out and uh just like
it review it wherever you can yeah and
it feels cool it's like most of my
the specials have been in theaters
that's the first one I did in a rock
Club where everybody's standing and then
like I walked through and you know I had
a metal band well I wrote a metal song
that opens up the show no way I love it
so it just felt more oh my God I can't
wait to experience I love it I love that
you did it right now and I'm the fastest
I've ever been okay good not now
that's why I'm dressed like this so I'll
explain this is my old man walking out
of it
you can see me walking around the valley
like an old man
I live near Ventura I'll come join you
on a walk I'll walk down like from the
405 to the other like to Tarzana and uh
let's do it the great thing about
walking on a trip you see different [ __ ]
it's interesting the whole way
you'll realize a little store was there
that you've driven by a thousand times
there's that nice 7-Eleven yeah I know
exactly yeah yeah
but we've got a nice one in the valley
sure the one on Stearns yes
are you guys ready to do a story
this was sent in by uh SB at losername
1990. okay here we go then he graduated
uh we are I feel like it might be easy
but we're gonna do it anyway we're gonna
play another round of who is the [ __ ]
okay so the way this works is these are
commonly put on Reddit where somebody
does something and go am I the bad
person here and throughout the course of
the story we may check in with you guys
I love when you check in because there's
a point who feels the [ __ ] oftentimes
I always think it's one way and then I'm
always wrong okay here we can say that a
lot okay headline is this
video of woman mowing her lawn while a
bride walks down the aisle causes mixed
reactions wait she's got a woman woman
knew that a wedding was going on nearby
and decided
the smoke this one's not gonna mow
itself I can't wait until later I'm
already I hate that you think that
lawnmower is the [ __ ] yes right now
but then I might change a couple who
wanted to make their wedding day special
by having it on the front lawn of their
house okay wound up experiencing a
rather rude Interruption after a
neighbor began mowing her lawn so you're
doing it in the front yard of your house
do you and Deb hates your ass dab
this year I mean we've all you can't
pick your neighbors you cannot pick your
name people think you guys have moved
into houses did you try to meet who your
neighbors would be before
certainly in L.A you just feel like
you're lucky enough to have a place
right like there's no way I haven't even
met the people on the other side of my
fence and it's been 15 years okay so I
know the guy likes Rush on Spotify so
we'll probably get along yeah you can't
be that bad no no he'll use a thought
he'll go to the last channel on Spotify
when he's out in the summer so but if it
is getty Lee
um no but that's yeah so your neighbor
in certain other areas where there are
no fences I mean front yard wedding
that's a little suspect too because I'm
on the side of the mower yes there's a
front yard wedding going on next to me
I'm going out with like anything I can
do to make noise
he hasn't played why is he call your
friend with the yelpie dog come over
here yeah bring the Yorkshire Spotify
Rush guy to play subdivisions really
loudly
don't do it all right as wedding guests
captured the couple's big day some
background noise can be heard disrupting
the ceremony
sides walked down the aisle was
accompanied by the sound of a motor and
according to the guests who captured the
moment the entire ceremony and so in
there is video and we'll post it up
we'll post it up but it's literally in
the video it's the they're not trying to
do vows and when you hear like oh yeah
like they're doing full-on yard work
yeah
come on I know I know the video had the
caption she continued through the entire
wedding and we could not hear the vows
of course you couldn't according to the
person who posted the video the woman
was well aware of the wedding taking
place however that didn't stop her
mowing at all
yeah
I'm oh here we should tell you something
Dan The Vows are all bullshits you don't
really need to hear it it's more about
like um The Tick tocker claims they
confronted the woman about the noise but
says she was extremely rude and did not
cease now would you go what are you
doing are you trying to find it oh I
gotta see this video
we are on camera I know
um so they they uh they used to go up to
her you have to say something right
but it's how you say it I mean because
I'm sure it has to know you're not going
to go hey I don't know if you're aware
that's super passive you're so sorry
late listen is there any you've heard of
weddings right yeah you know how those
were I mean that would have been the
most especially if that person sing hey
hey you know what's weird
you know I ran I hung out with do you
know Lisa delarios great Comics yeah so
sweet and so great and it literally is
part of one of the craziest stories that
like have ever happened to us we were
throwing a huge party you may have even
been at that party in La when we first
moved to LA on our house on Harper
Street it was Harper between like third
and first I feel like you were there
minor in you yeah we had like a huge
part we invited all of our comedy
friends over and this is like 99 1999
and we had this huge party and we
literally gave Flyers to all of our
neighbors just like hey come on buy the
party we'd love to have you so calm so
you don't call the cops also if it's too
loud let us know
I'll just knock on the door please you
guys are so nice they're nice we do not
want to get broken up we're like we're
inviting a lot of people so this is how
it was 99 we're like in the house making
a mixtape of our CDs to play during the
party so you don't have to keep changing
the site so it's and and it it is blast
music blasting phone rings landline 99.
I answer in the front room
I know it's it's you say hello and it's
our neighbor Susan from across the
street 45 years old we're like at the
time like 29 or something like that it's
like almost 20 years old than us single
always washing your car like a 1993 Saab
I was like she was trying she's like
watering the car with hopes it's going
to grow into a new better car right but
if you want to start like where the
water shortage started with her and then
work yourself backwards wash it every
day also really and what time of day is
this when she's calling you this is the
afternoon this is in the afternoon as
we're making it making the thing and we
had invited her also someone who was
like
and she is someone who worked out a lot
sure
in good shape maybe not the most
beautiful person in the world I can say
it that way so anyway but she calls up
and she says hello it's Susan and to
which I and then I pick up the phone and
I'm like hey music box in the background
it sounds like Lisa delarius it when she
says Hey to which I then say hey do you
have directions to our house and then
Jake at the moment I know that he does
not know
you're on the front line and you're I'm
on the back line he's in the kitchen
she's like yeah I have directions and I
was like okay great awesome we'll see
you later and she's like Hey listen I
was wondering is there any way if I
could can I bring a friend can I bring a
couple of friends and to which I then
said to her because I thought it was
Lisa Delirious comic sure the more [ __ ]
the better
Randy to our overtime across the street
neighborhood
I actually like I was like I'm not going
to be able to breathe it was like
she's like okay
okay
she did not show up at the party I
couldn't breathe
so the next morning after like this
massive party that I'm sure Brian posane
was over at uh she's watering her car
again I got so much
I go out to apologize to her for saying
it and my apology this is kind of like
what we were saying before in like you
know what a wedding is my apology was
like
super hole I was like I said you're my
friend yeah I thought you were my friend
I know how you talk to friends and I
maybe you don't know but like civilians
are different we're like we like really
people right or even worse he was like
comedians we don't care when people say
stuff that's offensive like weird we
don't take offense to it like other
people do and also like she's my friend
and you're not my friend
she said she was rude and did not cease
the mowing quote it was gonna get
violent so we just tried to ignore her
and did not feed in to make it any worse
this person is mad if you're gonna ruin
someone's but like come on you Ryan said
he would do it I know he was a joke some
people also
maybe Dr Brian just looking blankly into
the it's like a new Deadpool comic some
people uh also questioned whether the
couple had any history with the woman
which caused her to act this way
definitely however the tick tocker
confirmed that that's not the case yeah
they confirm on their side of the screen
oh good uh that no and no one had shown
the woman any contempt that's the only
deal too if you don't have a great
relationship with your neighbors and
like what you guys did with the Flyers
right we go around and you go hey we're
thinking about having our wedding if
anyone goes I wish you wouldn't do that
don't do it don't because once it gets
underway you will not you are not in
control
I go back to Brian what Brian said front
yard wedding is kind of like a weird
Flex you know unless they didn't have a
bad fire you'll see in the video it's
there's like an ocean in the background
like it's very picturesque you can see
why someone would want to have a wedding
yeah yeah but but still like at the very
least you go on all your names and go
hey we're having a small little ceremony
but we're having a party afterwards open
bar would love for you to come I still
think it's never fun you can mow your
lawn another time like this isn't the
only time you could ever mow your lawn
this is a vendetta well there were many
internet users criticizing the woman
some people thought the couple should
have been more understanding of their
neighbor people claim that the woman had
all the freedom to do her chores on her
own time but one user wrote so we all
have to plan our home maintenance around
someone's wedding I mean if you get
married you do
excuse me I mean how many times I have
to do this in my life with you guys
right I hope once right once I mean if
you get married at an event venue they
normally take care of risks like that
yeah I mean you did you did kind of like
put it out into the wild and hope that
it was just gonna work out right but on
some level as well you didn't pay for a
venue and like filming it's like filming
on the street like yes and the guy is
gonna walk by and be like yeah or like I
shot a movie yeah I shot a thing in a
park once yeah and you run the risk of
saying to somebody like hey man would
you be cool with moving of them going no
no and now you're in the show it doesn't
cost them anything to move they just
don't want to be dictated by you it's
like suddenly everyone lives in Alaska
they're like no one you can't tell me
what to do right it's like all right
fine I would say if you decide to do
anything in the wild like that in your
invitation from the jump you need to set
the table that like who knows what'll
happen we hope that we're going to roll
this with our Zoom shows we'd be like
hey in some level this isn't going to
work at some point they just gotta just
roll with it know that we love you right
right another user wrote I'm a pretty
busy person if I have to mow my lawn I
don't really care what anyone else is
doing if it's between the designated
noise allowance times which is such a
like by loss oh so you'll you'll you'll
be respectful of noise allowance but not
the one time these people get married
right not love alone personally okay so
I'll ask you guys this is the woman no
no I wish who do you think is the
[ __ ] who's the [ __ ] okay I mean I
think it's her ultimately but the people
set it up for Phil I think it's the
woman mowing the lawn but I do think
there's a little bit of [ __ ] if I had
to percentage-wise 87 woman mowing the
lawn 13 having a front yard wedding so
it's two wrongs and I know that doesn't
make it right but I mean she is
a little bit in the she's way more in
the wrong for doing it but they're a
little bit in the wrong for expecting it
to go perfectly in any neighborhood yeah
yeah what do you think Brian that's what
I think yeah okay good all right there
we go that's Story number two Jay you
got a little bit of Story number three
what do we uh give us a little teaser
um literally uh I will be giving you
your new nightmare for the rest of your
life okay great super all of that with
Brian post saying an arm ripped off this
guy's seen it all uh on dumb people town
right after this
hey guys welcome back to the show I want
to let you know about patreon if you
want to join our patreon 25 bucks it's
only five bucks 1.25 a week plus I have
three episodes cup of coffee a month and
so you get free episodes which here's
the new way we're doing it we are taking
your dumb stories from your life you
just send them in via email dptpodcast
gmail.com I believe that you don't think
you witnessed participated in was a
victim of at all and if you really don't
have nothing we all have I mean Brian's
told like I told the story on this
podcast is something done we all do it
we all do it you know somebody else
might go hey here's my dumb story here's
two stories from before 2005. great be a
contributor be a contributor and we'll
do that too and that's just for you
again five bucks for everybody and then
it's ad free episodes so you want to
join it patreon.com people town I
believe is what it is yes and it's
always awesome
story do that all right
I'm holding in my hands it's a quickie
it's insane okay uh sent in by Tasha
Riggs at triggy La is that you is she
you I have not heard that uh all right
this is is the headline dog poops on
woman's face who is sleeping with open
mouth he spends three Dreadful days in
the hospital oh my God that seems
excessive every day is in the hospital
did your dog sleep in the bedroom first
of all if that dog's on leash then the
owner is to blame I mean like if the
dog's on the leash and you bring the dog
I mean Brian is a dog lover a dog lover
dog owner I've known would you say that
dog's mad at the person yeah I think I
think it might it would be or really
well trained dogs pranking me
you got pranks watch this watch this hey
buddy it does take some level of I don't
Precision so did the dog poop in her
mouth his mouth open the dog had enough
of that [ __ ] so by the way where are
you laying like there's an area where
dogs like the my own dog likes to go on
the front yard over by this bush so this
woman would be laying in a certain area
that like do we get to guess how many
days they were in the hospital yeah uh I
did say it I know I'm [ __ ] with you
okay uh do you have a pet if yes then
kindly don't sleep with your mouth open
hold on important it's a dog saying get
over here I'm gonna [ __ ]
I just found out uh it says do you have
a pet if yes then kindly don't sleep
with your mouth open I don't think those
two things are so directly related no
you can have a pet and also sleep with
your mouth you would think yeah yeah I
mean just don't have an [ __ ] dog
that's right I don't have a dog that
like or don't like do something don't
withhold a treat right under that stuff
this could be the new Enter Sandman
sleeping with brown eyes all right stop
it we're gonna get sued this sentiment
is usually pretty well apparently I see
I think this sentiment is usually
reserved for cats because aren't cats
the ones that supposedly like if they
think you're dead will just like scratch
your eyes I think any animal would eat
you if they got hungry enough and you're
dead dogs definitely have so yeah people
put this on cats and I'm like yeah no
let's get hungry so like if you don't
feel like the cat would do a lot less
damage too because cats like eat with
their tongue and they're just like [ __ ]
like an everlasting Gobstopper yeah so a
woman I would just tongue you to lick
you to death oh my god a woman in
Bristol spent three to me would be like
an evening with Gene Simmons not to
bring it back to kiss but there you go
or Richardson all right a woman in
Bristol spent three horrendous days in
the hospital after her daughter after
her daughter's dog pooped on her face
while she was asleep so you know she put
this on the daughter this is the moment
like I told you your dog it's not my dog
it's my daughter's dog right she doesn't
know also there's people when you tell
them that their dog did anything wrong
they want to know what you did to
contribute with that's right how was the
dog well what did you do before you went
to bed right what was the last thing you
said to that time
we loved watching your dog but he did
Rip our Curtains Down and you're like
well what what did you guys have on
wow did you look at him funny did you
look at him don't look at him were you
whistling he doesn't like that okay I'm
gonna ask you this and I put it on my
Note did you cook with garlic because if
you cooked with garlic can I ask
something too after you're done with
this garlic thing did you raise your
eyebrows he does not like that so do
wait the dog ripped down the curtains
was your phone on vibrant your dog [ __ ]
on my face well what did you do what did
you yeah was your phone on vibrate were
you speaking in Spanish no no the lady
identified as Amanda gomo uh or gumbo
days feel excessive am I the only person
in the hospital yes even to maybe even
have to go to the hospital he ended up
in the hospital with a gastrointestinal
infection passed on by her dog who was
also ill with violent diarrhea okay so
the dog has consumed it oh God is this
and for some reason I'm picturing like a
cute little Frenchie I said shitzu
dancing it's perfect
in a Great Dane oh my God that ruins my
idea but it's way better this is 10
pounds of [ __ ] it sleeps up by their
head like in the bed and had diarrhea
and it just like right into the mouth
yeah oh God oh my God after the messy
accident the woman was kept under
observation for I gave it away three
days what if like this is the beginning
as we talk about Brian's great Comics
what if his like this is her origin
story as a superhero because she she's
like shitsu the the superhero she opens
her mouth and like Dogs come out I don't
know what she can do what are dogs
superpower like what can you so many
video games there's like this
hearing and smells
uh this uh they rehydrated her with
electrolytes and glucose we'll get out
of here on this okay her daughter's dog
how old is the woman is the woman who
sleeps with her mouth open and her
daughter's sick dog this is her daughter
this is her daughter I'll take care of
it as long where do you want to go I'm
gonna let you decide you don't have to
go first if you don't want to how old is
the woman how old is the woman who got
her mouth her face her face
62. 62 year old one that was he didn't
Flinch
53 53 years feels like a 53. I think
she's 71. I think I love all these
guesses I love it shout out your ham
radio so if you're listening yell at
your computer screen if you're watching
the name of the two the two books that
you can get right now Halloween party
and the secret history of the war on
weed secret is the one the name of the
new special which you can find
everywhere
look at that follow it and thank you for
being catch him live wherever you see
him he's so [ __ ] right I do a weekend
every year with some of the guys I grew
up with we call it nerdcation and uh we
just do comic books and deck building
games and stuff like that and I'm gonna
once you sign these I'm gonna be the
coolest guy at the cabinet hell yes yes
all right here we go this woman who died
the dog crapped in her mouth it's her
daughter's dog it's not her dog come on
was 51 years old
very good that's it that's the show Ryan
post saying you're the best dude thanks
for coming and hanging with us thanks
for getting dressed up thank you and uh
it doesn't matter he's got to walk the
valley old man walk in the valley he's
right here with us and oh [ __ ] we gotta
get back to work
[Music]
dum dum dum
stick around make a sound Thunder Down
these dump people town
[Music]